Mr. Hankey, the Christmas Poo, is probably
the world's most disgusting Christmas
icon. But he's also one of South
Park's most recognizable characters,
and has become a bona fide
symbol of the holiday season.
We're here to explore the history of
this gross but lovable Christmas mascot.
While it seems like Mr. Hankey, the Christmas Poo
might just be something that the reliably wacky,
gross, and crude South Park writing staff
squeezed out, the character predates the
series by more than two decades. The sentient,
singing stool sample was invented by South
Park co-creator Trey Parker's father in the
early 1970s. As Parker explained to Variety:
"When I was three years old, I had a bad
habit of not flushing the toilet after I
was finished. My mother asked my father to have
a little 'talk' with me about toilet flushing.
He told me that if I didn't, 'Mr. Hankey will
come out of the toilet and annoy you forever.'"
In other tellings, Parker has recalled his father
being a little more harsh, insinuating that if he
failed to flush, his leavings would transform
into Mr. Hankey, who would then come after
little Trey and try to straight-up kill him.
On the one hand, this is one of the grossest
ways to traumatize a child into good behavior.
On the other hand, it appears to have worked.
"Hiiii-dee-ho!"
Mr. Hankey makes his entrance in the
middle of the first season of South Park,
but has never become much more than a minor,
recurring character on a richly developed,
well-populated series. This low-key
fate wasn't set in stone, however.
Show creators Trey Parker and Matt Stone
initially had much bigger plans for the living,
laughing excrement, with Parker recalling
on a South Park DVD commentary track:
"Mr. Hankey was something we wanted to make even
in college. When we were making the South Park
shorts, we always talked about
making a short with Mr. Hankey."
That short film never got made, but some of the
plot points were ultimately used in "Mr. Hankey,
the Christmas Poo," the 1997 South Park
episode that introduces the character.
Stone explained a scene where the poo is revealed
to be alive. In the short that never got made,
Mr. Hankey would have just been a figment of
the imagination of a disturbed young child
who smears stuff on the walls and claims his poo
is sentient. The Mr. Hankey that made it to the
screen is just as gross, but at least his maker,
Kyle, can be afforded a little more respect.
South Park's origins lie in two crudely animated
short cartoons called "The Spirit of Christmas"
that Trey Parker and Matt Stone made in the
early 1990s. After seeing the first short,
in which Jesus fights Frosty the Snowman, Fox
network executive Brian Graden commissioned
Parker and Stone to make another cartoon he
could use as a Christmas card. After this,
Parker and Stone took a few meetings
about developing an animated series.
“Behold my glory.”
"Holy s---, it's Jesus!"
Rather than pitching adventures with the four
little boys from "The Spirit of Christmas",
Parker and Stone's initial pitch for a series
was The Mr. Hankey Show, an animated series
about the life-imbued piece of fecal matter who
was the focus of their unmade short cartoon.
Stan, Kyle, Kenny, and Cartman would have been
supporting characters with Mr. Hankey center
stage, commenting on life and current events.
Graden, Parker, and Stone's contact at Fox,
adamantly refused to put a show about excrement on
television, and so the writers heeded some advice
they'd been given and instead developed South
Park, a show about four kids living in a strange
town. The duo found corporate champions in Comedy
Central, where executives expressly told Parker
and Stone that they had no problem with Mr. Hankey
-and thus some very strange history was made.
Mr. Hankey debuted in the South Park episode
entitled "Mr. Hankey, the Christmas Poo." First
airing on December 17, 1997, it was a monumental,
watershed moment in the animated series' history,
with effects ranging far beyond the
mere introduction of a talking turd.
"Mr. Hankey, the Christmas Poo" is the first of
many Christmas episodes in South Park history,
and introduces many familiar South Park tunes,
including Eric Cartman's classic
number, "Kyle's Mom is a Big Fat",
and also, of course, Mr. Hankey's own
Christmas carol-style theme song. "Mr. Hankey,
the Christmas Poo" is also the first ever musical
South Park episode, predating both the movie,
South Park: Bigger, Longer, and Uncut, and Parker
and Stone's Broadway hit, The Book of Mormon.
Additionally, Mr. Hankey's
arrival coincides with the
introduction of two other South Park
characters. His very special episode
marks the debut of troubled kid Craig Tucker,
and that of guidance counselor Mr. Mackey,
who attempts to convince Kyle that he isn't
really interacting with a talking Christmas poo.
“In your screwed up little head,
he’s the only friend you have. Kyle!”
The holiday spirit of Mr. Hankey is so
strong that it ends up subverting one
of South Park's most famous and popular early
tropes. "Mr. Hankey, the Christmas Poo" is the
first episode where the frequently-killed Kenny
somehow doesn't die. Talk about groundbreaking.
Mr. Hankey's real world origins are rooted in
Trey Parker's childhood, but in the universe of
the TV series, the character's beginnings are a
whole lot muddier. In fact, it's actually never
quite revealed how Mr. Hankey came to be. Clues
to his origins are spread out over his occasional
appearances, which span two decades. They suggest
he's an ancient being of tremendous magical gifts.
In "Red Sleigh Down," he visits the
ageless Santa Claus, and the two appear to
be old friends. And while Kyle is the first
person in South Park to discover Mr. Hankey
when the magical creature pops out
of his toilet, Chef for some reason
already knows about the friendly piece of
feces. Mr. Hankey is clearly not just some
of Kyle's waste sprung to life, though if you can
believe it, that's still about as much as we know.
Mr. Hankey wasn’t always a holiday character, with
Parker explaining in a South Park DVD commentary:
"I'd actually been drawing Mr. Hankey
since I was a kid, [and I’d] been drawing
him with a little sailor's hat, instead of
a Christmas hat, since elementary school."
A remnant of this nautical Mr. Hankey survives
in a piece of obscure South Park ephemera.
In the opening title sequence of the unaired
original pilot episode of South Park, Mr. Hankey
briefly bounces across the screen, wearing a
primitive version of the hat. Bookending his time
in South Park, he dons the sailor hat once again
when he's thrown out of town in a 2018 episode.
After establishing Mr. Hankey, the Christmas
Poo as a bit of modern seasonal storytelling
on par with The Simpsons’ long-running Treehouse
of Horror episodes for Halloween, South Park and
Columbia Records capitalized on the popularity
of the character just two years after his debut.
In 1999, coupled with a TV
special of the same name,
Mr. Hankey's Christmas Classics hit
the shelves. The album features the
Mr. Hankey theme song and other South
Park holiday originals, such as "Merry
Christmas" as performed by Mr. Garrison, and
Kyle Broflovski's "The Lonely Jew on Christmas."
The novelty record proved to be a hit, ranking
among the top 40 best-selling holiday albums
of 1999, as reported by Billboard. In what
must have felt like an era-defining moment,
Mr. Hankey's Christmas Classics ended up
ranking just below A Charlie Brown Christmas,
and ahead of A Christmas
Album, by Barbra Streisand,
whom South Park depicted as the wicked
colossus Mecha-Streisand in 1998.
Prior to South Park's debut in 1997,
cable TV's most notorious animated series
was Nickelodeon's The Ren and Stimpy Show.
Created by John Kricfalusi, it features the
adventures of a rage-prone chihuahua named Ren and
his friend, a cat named Stimpy. In October 1997,
Kricfalusi debuted a web series that features a
character named Nutty the Friendly Dump, a jovial,
talking feces log. A couple months later,
Mr. Hankey the Christmas Poo, another jovial,
talking feces log, made his debut on South Park,
and Kricfalusi called foul, telling E! Online:
"I got nine messages on my answering machine
from people who said [South Park] took like
10 of your ideas and put them in
one episode. I suppose it could
be a coincidence; everyone likes dump humor."
South Park co-creator Trey Parker wrote an open
letter denying that Mr. Hankey was
a ripoff of Nutty the Friendly Dump.
After explaining that Mr. Hankey was the
invention of his father, Parker said,
"It is my hope that this personal letter will put
an end to your attempts to slander me and my poo."
The gesture worked, although a few days later,
Kricfalusi expressed a desire for Parker to,
at the very least, admit that South
Park was inspired by Ren and Stimpy.
As South Park's modern-day
Christmas legend tells viewers,
Mr. Hankey lives in toilets and emerges during
the holidays. His magical nature is undeniable,
but could it be possible that Mr. Hankey
has also made his presence felt in space?
After all, there is precedent set by the 1964
cult classic, Santa Claus Conquers the Martians.
In January 2019, NASA engineer Kevin M. Gill
tweeted a picture of the planet Jupiter,
captured by the Juno spacecraft the previous
September and then enhanced. The photo depicts
a gigantic oblong object on the surface of the
largest planet in the solar system. Said shape
is long, brown, and very closely resembles Mr.
Hankey, the Christmas Poo, as Gill pointed out.
As you might realize, this association
is somewhat appropriate, as Jupiter is,
after all, a gas giant.
According to a press release Gill sent to
HuffPost, "Mr. Hankey" is the unofficial
nickname for what is technically called a "brown
barge" or "cyclonic region" on the planet.
What's even stranger: The picture of this Mr.
Hankey-esque spot on Jupiter emerged just weeks
after South Park broadcast the episode in which
the Christmas character is forced into exile.
Having been thrown off TV, Mr. Hankey apparently
decided to take his magic to another dimension.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about South Park,
Christmas, and everything in between
are coming soon. Subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one.